hey Louie how are you hi how you doing
Andrew Andrew pleasure Jim Norton sends
his best he was very upset when he I'm
so said he loves I love you too
oh thank you very much I don't have the
history no no no you and Jim I'll be be
a short interview yeah bad guys go can I
get in that do you do that
do you like you have to assess a chair
like get there and go like that's
everything first of all how do I do this
without being embarrassing how do I do
this without you seeing my front butt
[Laughter]
front butts unite out there
well show man you got a lot thank you
it's so great watching these watching
somebody within the career as long as
yours and watching oh oh my phone's
missing oh boy my back but it's always
the last place you look it is true
always the last place you look what my
glasses are gone they're gone - well
don't worry I won't okay I know but it's
so irritating see where do you think
they are oh they gotta be somewhere
that's right let's see there are always
the last place you land they gotta be
somewhere somebody I'll just do it I'll
just forget about it because I don't
have any other classes with me so
Spencer's gonna find him Travis okay
Spencer's gonna find it don't worry okay
they're black you'll be in there from
Home Depot they're $4.99 oh so yeah you
don't have to replace those you can't
find them I've bought in years ago when
I was getting a toilet seat uh-huh have
you ever had to go in and you pass by
the toilet thing and they have I didn't
know they had so many different choices
for toilets nowadays especially if you
want to start going expensive or if you
want something you shoot water in your
butt
well that's the thing that's the big
thing in these Japanese toilets have I
know oh no I know sweetie are you are
you a bidet guy no have you got that
shells
it's incredible I've only heard great
things in car
just whisk you're lazy like I don't like
the wiping ritual at all
you don't know I feel like I'd still
wipe even with a bidet well you did you
dab I see yeah you dry off yeah yeah cuz
I've seen him they've the built in the
water shooters they have dryers on them
they have heated seats everything huh
yeah look at this I can find a way to
lay down no matter what with the kind of
luxury that you have in this radio
studio this is unbelievable they want
you to have on a balloon a must you must
be in good position here that's true
to have this spot first of all oh he is
low you've got a cloaking device on the
outside look in here come on it's just
to create intrigue the color I was able
to coordinate mm-hmm with the colors
blue Louise bass inlaid almost all the
way back this is like a latest life here
in first class this is so beautiful
hey can I get some more peanuts lady to
Jerry Lewis lady right do you fly
first-class when you fly I would
actually I yeah you got even when I
couldn't afford it I would try to get up
there you wouldn't hey I don't want to
crush this guy because you know a big
guy if somebody's coming down the aisle
and you start to slow it their seat
their eyes get real big like oh no well
if he's gonna sit with us have you see
what airlines have done now they take
the aisle in first class and the aisle
is actually way smaller between the
seats in coach so it's almost like
they're telling you if you have trouble
fitting through this aisle you're not
gonna like this yeah it all true it's
true
I've never been back there what's that
like yeah it's expensive to fly you
could buy a Buick for that what it costs
to go first class sometimes oh yeah I
know that's why I sit behind the wing do
you always sit behind the wing for the
most part yeah every safe spot is that
were you've read every now and then I
will treat myself to Economy Plus yeah
that's not bad you know I can fit an
economy plus No is that right good now
get a bulkhead seat yeah yeah both can
see is classic that's enough
for first-class I love 1d the very first
row why do you like the first row so I
can get out immediately and and not I
just don't want to stay in any longer
yeah legs your legs don't go all the way
up to me legs back yes let me just say
one thing right off say you know I love
you guys yes I have a goal today yeah my
dismantled I'm having fun just so you
know Jimmy I'm sending your chair right
anyway so tell me what your goal is um I
am going to put my glasses are these
nice for five bucks from Home Depot
come on the ironing right for especially
for as long as you've hung on to how
that wasn't true but you know it's
comedy you making up stuff you had me
going around that's easy
tell me what your goal is today hey mom
mm-hmm stories for my mother right but
you can read them too on Amazon right
now yes tell me only 20 bucks what's
good oh this should be 26 anyways nobody
know those first-class seats yeah so
what's the mole fourteen hundred and
twelve on the bestseller list
that's very down down from seventy nine
thousand I was 79 thousand that's
actually great last week when I started
now I'm at 1412 but I want to be in the
top ten so I'm just asking people if you
want to get a gift for your mother on
Mother's Day it's a great time to do it
this is a great time to do it the book
is a pretty brilliant concept you know
first of all of course you have Louie on
the cover gotcha he's become very famous
because of baskets portraying the mother
ah okay which Louie based on his very
own mother so that's why he's dressed as
as the as a mother right on the cover of
the book but it's basically it's kind of
like a memoir it is but it's told
through letters to his mom who's passed
away and it's the things that she missed
that he's done in show business in his
life and things like that yeah you know
like
it's true night you know I believe that
you know that the book will be a great
comfort to people about their moms I
really do and I'm really glad I got to
write it because I could apologize to my
mom for being a jerk when I was a jerk
and also I could explain to her Twitter
you know Instagram all those things the
internet that's yeah and get to see all
that stuff you know she she really was
gone in 1990 she didn't get to
experience well yeah I was reading that
you started by explaining the Internet
to her and then you had to get into
Twitter and then you had to get into
Instagram because it's like yeah I got
this thing going on on Twitter well let
me explain to you mom what Twitter is I
have a friend just got out of prison he
was there for 12 years and what do you
do some bad things
oh and that he's okay that's got to be a
miserable if my brother was in prison
for four years really yeah recently no
1901 ah yes No so Wow knowing that in
the 70s though right he was a
safecracker he was a really good safe oh
wow he was all yeah yeah but he was a
really good anyways I did a good rhyme
on your story no but the the the crazy
thing about the last 12 years is like
you know technolon technology has
changed in the last 12 years a lot are
you kidding me so the first iPhone you
but this so iPhone 10 that we have now
that's because it's only been 10 years
you're talking about this guy goes who
gets locked up two years before the
iPhone yeah tonight's incredible so
hanging out with him was so much fun cuz
he's experiencing all these things for
the first time like your story with your
mom works you know explaining Twitter
like so you talk him how to you know are
you telling harbucks he does you want to
go Starbucks I am I just had coffee he's
like yeah you know I've never been a
Starbucks
takes a bite out of the cake flap this
guy's been in prison for 12 years yeah
it goes he goes hey what the [ __ ] is in
here I had these in prison and how do
you explain Twitter to them do you go
like so he's like so you're telling me I
can just go on here [ __ ] on any
celebrity and they'll read it you don't
get to this is what you're telling me I
could talk to the president you can
explain it to him like remember when you
are on tier 1 now you could talk to tier
4 Vinnie dick is my ass so your brother
was in prison in the 70 yeah I think it
was seventies yeah so by the day twice
he was in so I think sixties and
seventies was the second time also for
safe no but if the first time was
writing checks oh so he was he was just
looking for a scam he was he was well he
accidentally got into you know being
with the Kansas City mob and stuff like
that so he wasn't really he was the
first famous person in my family because
the FBI came to our house that's a great
source mobster yeah Anderson hey I don't
know what accent that was but who's a
chef - so after he gets out of prison
the second time because when you go
change his life then he did and what did
he do for a living then he started
lecturing police departments about how
dumb they were really in his words yeah
they're his work yes that's actually a
good idea
yeah like he would say this is what you
look for if you're you know yeah that's
the catch me if you can store exactly
right I love that that's the thing if
you break the law and you're really good
at it right they'll hire you right right
you just can't be mediocre at breaking
the law no you you're right you're
exactly right
yes yeah listen this guy he fooled us a
thousand times let's hire exactly right
it makes sense it really makes sense and
I would imagine in that life like you
can't get out of jail and just get a
regular job where the money's coming in
at a regular pace like you got to do
something where you're making
real money to do something like public
speaking is a great example of what yeah
I mean you're the greatest thing about
this world now yeah is if you present
whatever you're doing right you can you
can you can monetize it yeah yeah we got
more power to present now yeah unless
you get on car salary to present you
should power to present that let's do it
yes fantastic Tony Robbins what company
are you with
there's no gatekeeper in the audience
that's right
go right to the audience that's right
like there's no life put me on that
forms our immediate like you and I can
present something without going through
that third party right and the minute
like even then even at the bare minimum
the minute YouTube is like well there's
a Community Guidelines thing here so you
can't be on YouTube anymore all right
I'll be on Vimeo all right I'll be over
here have you had that experience with
YouTube yeah yes so what did you do then
you went to Vimeo no I did I have
another YouTube channel I was like all
right I'll do my live shows over here
okay and that's just how easy it was
that awesome yeah they take it down it
was it was it was the technical isn't
yet and they don't tell you they hit me
with a Community Guidelines strike for
spam even though there was no spam and
they're like yeah we're gonna stick by
this so I couldn't do live broadcast on
the YouTube channel for three months
well I was like well luckily I had
already started this other YouTube
channel I just do live ones over here
well and then bring the videos over to
this one like you know there's what an
amazing world and it's amazing that you
can sit here and broadcast all over the
world incredible my right incredible
cause you know people know this show
right I always mentioned that I've been
on here that's excellent
yeah that's a really good thing yeah
right so is that is how you could say I
mean when you're stand-up when you're
traveling you can tell the shows that
have impact because right a few people
no matter where I go they go yeah listen
you know Jim says great I've heard you
want I mean Howard obviously had that if
it was a massive Howard was the
beginning of that kind of and what were
the guys in Bob and poverty they were
big right but uh you know like all those
you know early on comics went on the
radio they didn't have another they
didn't have TV they couldn't get on TV
at the beginning
and they were saying we know he's
friends'll media they don't have radio
station I tried to get on the top radio
station so that I could hit the mark the
club said where I was gonna get a bonus
yeah that's back to when all the radio
stations had power because they knew
that yeah and so they'd be like no you
really have to impress me if you want me
you have to be funny on the radio for
them and write them look good right and
would you do bits would you go like a
radio I would mm-hmm there's well I mean
I did my bits I set them up and you know
you have to learn one thing in radio you
have to learn how to like you have to
learn how to take control like you did
with what I said you went and took that
into a story about your friend which was
perfect which is what it's about
so then imagine an audience here is that
they go all his friend has just got out
of prison that was interesting I look up
his thing see what he's doing now it's
much more sophisticated but back then it
was hey we should go down to Charlie's
and see Louie
right because he's so you're saying
Andrew Shaw was sitting here he's
looking at Louie Anderson he's be like
this guy's not stealing segments from me
look at me and my prison hold on a
second because I just want to check its
called hey bond to $20 like I said hey
mom is the name of the book and it's all
this stuff Louie's done and look I mean
the career career is just incredible do
you start looking at show business with
a new optimism because I'm sure that you
didn't realize we probably never
realized what's really gonna hit ever
realize you know what I mean
no you're exactly right I never I never
saw myself in this position right that
baskets are now gonna create this whole
other chapter in your career where
you're as big as you've ever been right
you know I was pretty like I had lots of
juice at one time right at the top you
know HBO special right all that and I
host the family feud and you know did
all that but and I had a cartoon you
know that was number of us every year
and so but this is different this is a
new guy's a brand new thing just like
you say it has a different I guess the
reason that it's different is because
for some reason I never this I haven't
been in this arena
where I am in a prime-time comedy show
you know baskets with Zach Galifianakis
you know that's a big deal kazakh often
a cos is you know he's the generation
after me mm-hmm
in comedy he's probably one of the top
alternative comics if you want to look
at it that way he's a big movie star he
probably has more you know fans
worldwide
then from the hangover then most people
do and I think he's hugely respected and
I'm playing a woman right but not a guy
playing a woman I'm playing a woman my
whole goal when I get in there is to
make Louie Anderson disappear right I
don't want you to say that's Louie
Anderson playing a woman I want you to
forget that I'm playing a woman and I
want you to fall in love with that
character or have empathy for that
character or bond with that character
that's my whole goal I think that's why
it works because as sort of out of the
box as it is you're committing to it I'm
coming I'm so like I don't let them call
me Louis right on the set do you do do
you go method I I don't know I mean
people say do I go method right you know
I never really studied any method acting
I just don't want to be called Louie I
want to be called the character mm-hmm
so is if that's method then I'm going
method mm-hmm but I'm going mom could
this book that you see here wherever it
is you have it you see the picture of my
mom I mean I was looking at that you
know that's who that's a person I'm
playing I'm stealing all of her nuances
all of my mom's looks all of her pursed
lips all of her disappointment all of
her approval and I'm putting it in this
character and I resemble her
so it's an easy and what's great is yeah
you know when I do that's my mom and
you're not playing it for like the cheap
laughs no I in a dress and it's like the
comedy comes out of the natural places
in the grammar you're not playing a guy
in a dress you're playing a woman that
sounds like people go what do you do
well okay we were at fourth 1,400 yeah
well yeah where are we at I think we're
the same spot here guys things have
slipped have things there's a Friday but
that's okay here's one more thing to say
to people huh my new special big
underwear is also right on that same
page that's number one on iTunes I think
that's what they say but I can't figure
it out take it what about the big
underwear thing it was a big controversy
in might with my group my team mm-hmm
they said big I go I want to call it big
underwear and they go why I go cuz when
you're looking at the TV mm-hmm and you
look on the thing what am I gonna watch
gold rush right Deadliest Catch right
naked and afraid Louie Anderson butter
no one wants to see Louie Anderson
butter right Louie Anderson big
underwear people go on to see that it's
a better name is he gonna be in big
underwear he's right right don't you
follow you know all these what word is
called you're special you're next
special what would it be what would be
their name I mean I have no idea I don't
have any all right I didn't mean to
throw you into this any any joke I guess
it would be Danish what would you call a
not something you wanted people to see
though of yours okay at Vegas Jim Norton
and Sam Roberts yeah hopefully you'd
have to have another thing like
dangerous why was I click on it again
Jason's
Dangerous Liaisons would be a great name
there you know I'm right you a year
comic I didn't know yeah and I apologize
I'm performing at the Lois Anderson
theater in the palace station just
really I have you know they I was
waiting for the right time you know that
little theater was so much fun do you
know that Marty are you Marty Allen yeah
that's so true it was a terrible room of
things weren't going well don't know how
much they can eat a dog's death oh my
god yeah I was filling in for you you
must have gotten some you know project
or something like that yeah to go so he
had a sandwich
so I went and oh man one of the shows
there are only four people there this
was one this is my Vegas draw at night
but here's think one of the guys was in
a wheelchair and had like a smoking
thing so he couldn't speak he had to
speak through the oh yeah hello there
yeah one of them was the woman who was
pushing him around so it's really just
three people three it was just one of
them was insistent it was oh man it was
a wild but the room itself it's a great
little great little room but you're not
little enough that for whoa no can still
he would have thought he had a crowd it
was much bigger than this room though
really yeah it was it was a bigger but
da about that room you know what they
said to me one day
that's it they're nice people and I'm
friends of them they're the people who
bought the UFC the people own palace
oh oh really WM e no they're the people
who owned it before the fatigue uh
brother yeah they owned all the station
casinos and they said to me one day
we're gonna make this into a slot room
yeah and I said well how much could a
slot bring in and they said about a
hundred and forty thousand dollars a
week one machine or something like that
Wow I said how much yeah but there's no
way I could argue with them ago well I
could pack this is never gonna work
anyways I'm glad that you played that
how often would you perform late how
many shows four or five days a week
oh so you were living in Vegas that was
right I still live in Vegas I had a room
for ten years I had the the catch rising
star room at the at the Excalibur for
six years then I went over to Paulo
station for three years and then I went
downtown to the plaza for a couple years
do you like that better than touring or
does it drive you crazy do you know I go
back and forth I love the touring but
I'm I could do another in-house show
again yeah because by popular cuz I have
a new audience with basket absolutely
does that does that kind of blow your
mind that people are like yeah from
baskets and they don't know ladies yeah
yeah well that's true cuz these people
are coming and they don't know my comedy
so I don't know who what they think
afterwards and I don't know if they're
gonna go and see comedy
that's another thing because sometimes
people watch TV don't go see Tom go
don't go see the it's alright because
it's not stand-up it's a sitcom and it
does not always it's hard to get people
to leave their house man it's true yes
you're competing with some and I would
say people I wouldn't they say to me
you're gonna open us a comedy club I
don't know
it's only three nights a week comedy
okay
yeah rent for seven it works right a
Saturday and Sunday and only the first
show Friday I almost killed myself on a
second show for like seconds better yeah
but you I bet you're crazy I don't know
if I'm crazy dangerous up there cuz you
seem dangerous you're in terms of what
may be edgy maybe I say yeah I get
warmed up for the first so I get my own
all that kind of stuff and then by the
second and you need a show to get your
rhythm come on yeah goddamn professional
but you only do it an hour right when
you only do know I do 75 minutes minimum
okay so you're doing but meeting like
you'll never do 15-minute sets 15 yeah I
see what you mean no I get what you mean
you're always doing an hour 15 I get you
okay so you know pound it into you know
we start doing an hour from the 15 the
pacing is all different so yeah you want
to go clobber clobber clobber all right
let me just relax with these people let
me ask you a question do you try to
crush it so the next guy flounders cuz
that used to be the thing in the old
days you would try to destroy the next
guy or own the room maybe right that's a
better way putting it but like when
people used to try to do that get
competitive
I would always you know like I never
tried to do that I always tried to you
know give a good intro to the next
person you talking about liking in Caly
like at the store where you would bring
the guy up for the Empire where you
bring them up anywhere yeah everywhere
not that way right I'm not competing
against the next guy or anything I want
to do is the best set I can possibly do
with the jokes that I chose to do there
and then you know whatever happens after
happens after I can't I mean in New York
you guys aren't even generally watching
the rest of the show
yeah yeah no that is I hope you're
bombing yeah I don't think people hoped
you're bombing I think they just want to
do you know leave their mark yeah you
leave that to mark their territory but
let me ask you a question
what's your first joke usually can I ask
sure what is it
what am i doing man I like trying to
like have something what do you what is
your always your go-to of things look a
little like I got to get these people
right away oh if I need something really
strong it's gonna this gonna hit I mean
I I don't mean to put you on the spot no
to be honest like I so like I'll do a
new a new hour every time I come or new
45 and every time I come back into a
market so like whatever I'm working with
there I have like the stronger bits and
I'll go there but usually it's something
kind of quick to hit depending on who I
offend right like I'm doing something
that really pisses the women often in
the group I won't pay in there I have to
double down yeah it's a go and I've
realized that that will make them almost
respect me more that I didn't back off a
second well the audience wants to be
owned in that weird there anything
always true it's like a horse to be on a
horse wants to be wrong and now that
you're in control they really don't get
it they're like a dog yeah if they're in
control it's no not as much fun like a
dog who needs to be disciplined and is
looking to be rewarded for good behavior
Sam went down this leg I wanted to know
if how you guys at baskets dealt with
louis c.k getting taken off as it was
Tom executive you know Louie took
himself off all that stuff yeah people
wouldn't lose their job and you know he
did it you know need any made a really
good apology were you worried an apology
no I was never worried about the show or
anything Wow weird I thought I don't
like what is he there's one part I I
don't know you go go with this if that's
what you want to do I just I I don't
like all right first of all I don't
really see that anything that he did
wrong you know I mean I mean he and then
III just don't see him as the bad guy I
really don't you know he asked
permission after that what else you want
from a human being
well I think this
Constance's but I mean you know I think
but I wasn't there I don't know you know
I I see what you're saying that a
certain point in time like you gotta
treat people like human like adults if I
ask you permission you have the right to
say yes or no like come on and then the
other thing is he apologized I think he
apologized for having for them admiring
him it's like it's now that's wrong a
woman can admire someone that she's
asleep
well you can't admit you can't believe
somebody at the Michael Uslan but if
somebody admires you
well no admiration is different from
liking if you admire somebody you're
looking up to them and if somebody looks
up to you and you kind of take advantage
of that by asking them something knowing
that they kind of have to say yes or
they're gonna because this is oh this is
kind of coming out of nowhere you get an
entertainment why do we jerk off
obviously right so that there's an
there's a there's some admiration
dynamic there so there's probably easier
to find a mate so you can have children
like I don't know if Louie was trying to
have children no let me just say this
let me say this I think that when people
are in position just because they say
yes doesn't mean that they're not
vulnerable to the question being asked
so I think right that's that's where the
admiration comes that's what you have to
say and that Louie explained it I
thought really well and I thought it was
good he apologized and I thought it was
sad for the whole situation and
unfortunate and I thought that he comes
back and and works in comedy again I
think he will and I thought it was good
that he owned it and he admitted his
faults and then and then kind of moved
on I was just curious if anybody if they
were at baskets you guys were worried
that like Oh what does it mean for the
show or you knew that well you know zach
has always worked I've always worked
Jonathan crisis always works so if right
I mean you can't you can't we were more
concerned for everybody involved right
though not for ourselves I'd be honest
with you we're not we were not saying oh
my god best thing people realize like
there are a lot of people on these shows
that writers is their first job writing
write there's a guy who operates the
sound yeah might be his first
opportunity it's like you clip one guy
because you're trying to make a
statement or you're
you know I don't be virtuous you clip
another hundred people